RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK.
Well, thank you all for coming
to this Google Play Games
Developer Summit today.
There's quite a lot of
familiar faces in the audience.
Very nice to see you.
For those that don't recognize
me, my name is Richard Hyndman.
I'd like to think that I'm
your Guy Dangerous for the day.
Avoiding overrunning session
times and finding treasures--
digging up treasures from
each of the speakers.
But there's two
problems with that.
I think the first one is in
a very, very recent poll,
not that many people know
who Guy Dangerous is.
Blank faces.
Anybody?
One person with Guy Dangerous.
No.
Dammit.
That was supposed to work.
Guy Dangerous, being the lead
protagonist from Temple Run.
And the second
problem being, I'm
probably a lot more
like Minion Dave.
Just trying to avoid a bus
smashing me in the face
right now.
I've also got some very,
very bad tech jokes
up my sleeve which I'll pull
out if necessary, later on.
So hopefully it
runs all smoothly.
We've got a fantastic
set of speakers lined up
for you today.
We're going to run into all
the details of the Play Games
services, and why
Google is doing gaming.
With Play Games
services, Google is
aiming to bring you a very
powerful cross-platform suite
of tools and services for you
to enhance your gaming user
experience, increase engagement,
and improve revenues.
So with that, I'd like invite
on stage Thomas "Schree-ber",
Schreiber-- I knew I was
gonna get that wrong-- E-I,
Schreiber, who's going to
talk to us about why Google is
in gaming.
Thomas.
THOMAS SCHREIBER: Good
morning, everyone,
and thank you for coming
here to our office in London.
And it's actually
quite exciting.
This is the first
time-- I mean, obviously
we've had a number of
Google Developer summits.
But this is the first time that
we have one that is in Europe
and dedicated only to gaming.
That's quite great.
Let's maybe start
with a bit of honesty,
because this is a
developer summit.
Who of you have actually written
real code in the last seven
days?
That's pretty good.
It's impressive.
And for those who didn't
raise your hands, don't panic.
You can stay here.
The conference is also for you.
We'll cover all aspects.
And I have to
confess, I myself--
it's been actually
a long time that I
have written serious code.
So I feel with you who weren't
able to raise your hands.
Although a few weeks
ago I actually started
again working on code, and
actually working on games.
I started teaching 9 to
11-year-olds how to code.
This is using an
environment called
Scratch where they
actually develop games.
And it's super, super
inspiring to do this and see
the excitement of children.
But I can also tell you
that of all the things
that I have to do, this is
the most challenging thing
that I have to do-- to
try to crowd control 9
to 11-year-olds, being
excited with their games.
The hope of this program is
that they'll find a [INAUDIBLE]
with this kind of topic.
They stay interested
in technology.
They consider education
in this space.
And then in a number of--
obviously in a couple of years,
when your companies have
all grown tremendously,
and you need a lot
more developers,
then I will have personally
gotten the developers for you.
But not only is it
me who helps out
trying to grow the
gaming industry.
Clearly, it's a huge
growth opportunity.
That's why you are all here.
You're doing great stuff.
And Google is also investing
heavily in that space.
For example, in Cologne
at GDC last year,
we announced that our favorite
video format-- a TrueView
that some of you may know from
YouTube, this skippable ad
format-- that we made this
available on games on the web.
And of course it's available
on mobile apps as well.
And then just last week
at GDC in San Francisco,
there were just so
many announcements
on product
improvements that even
I am struggling to
remember all of them.
And we'll go through
them throughout the day
in more details.
So importantly, your
game is the key, right?
You are doing great
at developing games,
and that's the most
important thing that matters.
But the world has become
quite complicated.
There are so many
things that you
need to consider on top of
actually making a great game.
You need to ask yourself, how
do I make the infrastructure so
that it scales with your game
as it becomes more popular?
How do you actually
distribute your game, so
that you get millions
of users using it?
Once you have the
users in your system,
how do you engage the
users more deeply?
And last but not
least, you might
want to make a lot
of money with it
as well, so you can pay
your development team.
And so you need to find
the right systems in place
so you can monetize well.
And what I want to do today
is give you a brief tour,
running through
the Google services
on how they can help you
with those specific points.
So let's start with
taking the work away
on the infrastructure, to
make your games scalable.
You might have heard of this
operating system, Android,
before.
So clearly, we are
putting a lot of effort
in developing the
SDK, making it work on
as many devices as possible.
Android 4.4 KitKat has
been out for some time.
So I'm sure you're
all familiar with it.
But with this release, I feel
we've taken it another level,
making it available
on even more devices.
We would encourage you to
develop natively on the SDK,
to really benefit
from the efficiency
and the responsiveness that
you can get on those devices.
And of course, we also
have put in a lot of effort
on the developer support so that
you can code, debug, and test.
On the Google Play Games,
this is a great piece
of infrastructure, so that a
number of real life problems
that you have, or that
you should consider
to make your games
more interesting--
such as multiplayer support,
or keeping scores, et cetera--
that this level of services
can take care of it
so you can focus on the
core aspect of your game.
And clearly we heard
you, that if you really
want to support
multiplayer games,
it needs to be available
across operating systems.
And I believe that was
one of the announcements,
that it's not only Android,
but also iOS and support also
for web.
Cloud Save has been
out for some time.
But let me share one of the
frustrations that I have,
as a gamer.
Like many people in the room,
I have multiple devices.
You've probably all
seen this chart,
that you start in the morning
with your mobile phone.
You commute to work.
Then during the day, you
use your laptop, desktop
more heavily.
Then you commute back.
You use your phone, and then you
use your tablet in the evening.
A lot of people do that.
It's not just me
who's doing that.
So I find it very frustrating
that when I'm at home
and I want to use the laptop
I can't play any of the games.
Because a lot of
you still force me,
that if I start
playing your games
I have to start from scratch.
I spent so much time and
effort to go up to this level,
and of course when
I switch device,
I want to continue
with that level.
So please, just for me,
please develop your games so
that you save the score
and the level somewhere.
I think that the Google
Play Games service
is a great and
easy way to do it.
But if you want to do it another
way, just please do it for me.
And of course it's
not only mobile,
but we also have a
great set of tools
that helps you on the web.
So specifically, we
have a set of APIs
as part of the Chrome packaged
apps, that really allow you
to have web-based games
using HTML, JavaScript, CSS,
so that you can create the same
experience-- so that they're
as powerful as a native app, but
they're as safe as a web app.
It's not just
user-facing technology.
A lot of things need to go
in the background as well,
to make your game scalable so
that when it really takes off,
your game works.
And what we have done is--
exactly the same technology
that we use at Google to
make our system scalable--
we make that available to you
as a Google Cloud Platform
service.
I actually look forward to
the session later from Kaj
from MAG Interactive,
who's going
to share his experience of
how this is working for him.
So I hope that has
given you some ideas.
I'm sure you know some
of these weren't exactly
new things, of what services you
can use from Google that helps
you with the
infrastructure aspect.
But of course, you
want to get to users.
You want to get
millions of users.
You want to get hundreds
of millions of users.
So let's go through, what are
the tools that we can help you
with that challenge.
The first one is
again an obvious one,
and Dan will speak to that in
more detail, of how you really
get the best out of the
Google Play Platform
to distribute the game.
But the numbers
speak for themselves.
50 billion downloaded apps.
Another 2 billion every month.
Clearly, this is something
to look into, and really
optimize for you.
Just as we had before,
don't forget the web.
The Chrome store is
really a fantastic way
to distribute web
versions of your game.
And it has hundreds
of millions of users.
It is an opportunity that you
should definitely think about.
And I have a surprise for you.
Advertising actually does work.
Obviously, people
will use your game,
ultimately because
it's a great game.
If you have a game that's not so
great, no level of advertising
is gonna help with that.
But what you can do is
just to get more users
to actually discover your game.
So whether it's-- which
this screen is depicting--
whether it's a focused
text search campaign--
so if a user is
searching for your game,
or is searching for
something very similar,
that you direct
them to your game.
Or whether it's a
re-marketing campaign
that you have a user who
has played very frequently,
and somehow they have stopped,
to remind them about it.
Or a re-marketing campaign,
because you have now a game
that you think would
interest the same user.
Or you want to
attract completely
new people, new players, and you
use more rich engagement ads.
Either videos or
display ads, so that
you can really tell the story of
the visual appeal of the game,
and create that experience.
It definitely does work.
Now once you start
paying for users,
you have to look
into metrics that you
spend your money wisely.
The cost of user acquisition
is not necessarily
the most important aspect.
So let's just assume
that the game that you
want to distribute is
actually a free game,
and you want to make money
through in-app purchases
or through advertising.
So no matter what you
have spent to acquire
that particular user, if that
user only downloads the game
and doesn't actually
play it, that
was not a very smart investment.
And so really look
for-- is that you
need the deep analytics
to figure out,
how do you get the
return on you investment?
How would you get that user
who was actually making
the purchase, is making
the in-app purchase,
or is playing the
game long enough so
that you can show them enough
ads that it actually pays off
for you.
One of the great things where
our product suite really helps
you, is that we now have very
deep integration between AdMob
and analytics, so you can easily
see that segmentation to really
understand which campaign
is working for you and which
isn't.
So now we're in a good state.
You have hundreds of
millions of users.
Clearly they will
stay in your game,
because it's a great
game experience.
But what other services
can Google help you with,
just to deepen the
engagement even further?
First one-- and we'll hear
about that later today as well--
I think it's the next
session, actually--
on how to have
multiplayer support.
I won't go too much into detail.
But in essence, the more
you can get your users
to play with their friends,
play against their friends,
share things with their friends,
the more they are delighted,
and the better the
experience is for them.
And this is a solution that
we make available to you
so you don't have to do a
lot of coding around it.
Of course the same
is true for the web.
And I just wanted to point
out-- one thing that I get a lot
of positive feedback from
publishers who have a strong
web presence, is that if you use
the Google+ sign-in process--
similar to Google Play that
you can purchase something
on the web and it gets
downloaded to your Android
device-- when a user logs in on
your service using the Google+
functionality, you have the
ability to directly download
and install the mobile app that
you want on the user's devices.
So I think that's
another great way
how to distribute
your applications
Let's see how well
you know your YouTube.
And anyone from Google
is not allowed to answer.
Who knows what is the most
popular channel on YouTube
by number of subscribers?
AUDIENCE: Probably PewDiePie.
THOMAS SCHREIBER: Exactly.
He's got 25 million subscribers.
And it's incredible.
If you think about all the
content, all the videos, all
the channels, it's
actually the gaming sector
that is the number one.
I think this is an area that
is almost like a hidden secret.
And more can be made of it.
Gaming content is
incredibly popular on video.
And Ibrahim will go
into more details later.
But because it is
like that, it's
good to think-- to both use
it as a promotional tool
to show the power of your
games, the experience
that people have--
but also think
about in your games,
either using video actually
in the games, or if someone has
had a nice gaming experience
can you use, for
example, YouTube APIs,
that they can share that gaming
experience with their friends.
And then obviously, you want
to listen to your users.
You want to have a game
where the comments they give,
the ratings they give is high.
If you have high ratings,
your ranking is higher,
you get more users, you make
more money, life is good.
And we have a mechanism
to give that feedback.
So focusing on
quality is important.
At the same time,
what is crucial
is don't just put out
your game and then
hope that users will love it.
Because the reverse
can also happen.
That if users aren't happy
they give you bad ratings,
and then everything
spirals down.
So what we would recommend is
that you use the alpha and beta
testing tool that we have.
So you can test it out with
a trusted group of gamers.
And they will give
you the feedback.
And then in a dialogue
you can improve your game.
And only when you know you are
really ready you push it out,
and you got much more success.
Right.
So now we come to last section.
You have a scalable game.
You have reached lots of users.
They stay even more
engaged with the game,
spending more time because
of all the social features--
YouTube engagement, et cetera.
But I guess most of you actually
want to make money out of it.
The obvious, and very,
very important mechanism,
is of course to sell your game.
And with Google Play
supporting to sell your game
in over 130 countries, that's
of course a great opportunity
how to make money.
But life is more complicated.
Clearly, this is a
fantastic revenue stream,
how to sell money-- not
selling money, making money.
But the sad truth
is that when you
look behind the
actual numbers, it's
a very, very small
percentage of users
who are willing to pay
money for your games.
A recent study that
I have read claimed
that the majority of revenue
made from in-app purchases
or from up-front purchases
is less than 0.2 percent
of your users.
So if that is the case, then you
should ask yourself, well what
about the other 99.8
percent of the users.
Are you OK to not make
any money out of them?
Personally how I think
about this challenge is,
I think it's less a question
whether you personally
think ads are a
great thing or not.
But users have a preference.
So some users are willing to
pay money to get an experience,
and some are not.
And for those who are not
prepared to make money
advertising, I think is
a very legitimate way
for you to make money
for all the hard work
that you have done.
And actually, we have
worked very hard on this.
I think it would be fair to
say that two years ago, AdMob
was merely a demand platform,
that we help you to get ads.
But it has grown tremendously.
It is now a fully working
advertising solution,
in that it's deeply
integrated with Google Play.
So for example, if
you want, at run time,
to figure out, should I actually
have an in-app purchase ad,
then we have that
integration and it
puts you directly
to the Play Store.
It also is deeply
integrated into analytics,
which is very important.
Because those users who
pay you a lot of money--
well maybe, even
though you love ads,
you may not want to
show them any ads.
And you need exactly
that segmentation--
getting all the signals out of
your application from analytics
all combined, so
that you can dice
and slice the user
to really give--
to really use the optimal
monetize strategy.
Now clearly, you are in control.
But get the most out
of this opportunity.
So this is one way how to do it.
For those users who don't
want to pay for your app,
you can have a display ad.
But of course that's not
the only thing how to do it.
I think another
great way how to do
it is to have more
engaging formats.
And I think the skippable
ad format that we provide,
I think is actually another
fantastic mechanism.
So let's say-- clearly not
in the middle of the game,
but once the user has
reached a certain level--
and it's the kind of user who's
not giving you money anyway--
why don't you show
them a skippable ad?
And then the user has a choice.
They can either skip the ad,
and continue playing your game.
And that's fine, because they're
not interested to see the ad.
And so the value to the
advertiser's also not so great.
Because they want the audience
to engage with their ad.
Or, they actually decide
that they want to see the ad,
and then it's fantastic
for the advertisers
and they're willing to pay
a lot of money for that.
And so this is the
experience that we provide.
I just wanted to mention, given
that at Google the majority
of revenue comes
from advertising,
clearly this is our
bread and butter.
And the tools that
we use internally,
we also make available to you.
So if you are a very
large games company,
and you have your
own sales force that
goes out in the market
and sells it directly,
obviously we can offer
you the same tools
that any big company
uses to really make
that a scalable process.
And it's all fully integrated.
So it works with AdMob
and it works with video,
and it works across
all platforms,
and it's all the same system.
And I even take a personal bet
that no matter what advertising
solution you have-- because
of all this deep integration--
I would take a personal bet
that we would generate more
revenue than any other system.
So that was kind of
a marathon running
through the different products.
We will hear more details
in the later session.
And I hope it has given
you an idea of how
we can make-- how we can help
you in the development process,
to make your games
more scalable.
How we can help you to
generate more users,
whether it's from
organic traffic
or whether it's
from paid traffic.
The tools that you can leverage
so that your game is more
engaging.
And last but not
least, how you can
make as much money as possible.
Because at the end of the day
you're running a business.
But let's not keep forgetting
the most important thing
is that you continue
writing fantastic games.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]